the 10 Essential Elements for smart
language learning this is the title of
the book that I released last week and
let me tell you the response has been
amazing hundreds of people have bought
the book and I'm so glad
for all the responses for all the
positive reactions and the kind words so
thank you for that now in this video I
want to talk to you about two things
first how this book came about and
second the two biggest lessons I've
learned about language learning from
writing this book
so like any other big project writing a
book takes time takes energy and you
need peace of mind and continuity to
make it happen
and the problem is that a lot of things
happen in these months like health
issues relationship ordeals never ending
bathroom Renovations and everything in
between so that kind of slowed me down
but I think that the thing that slowed
me down the most was the fact that we
initially and by we I mean my team and I
we come up with a different book
and the reason why we had to scratch
that and start all over again was
because this book did not feel like
something personal sure it was
jam-packed with a lot of strategies a
lot of tactics a lot of ticks tips and
tricks but at the end of the day it was
not personal it was not emotional and so
we scratched that and we started all
over again but the point I want to make
here is that when you tackle such a big
project and you set a deadline for
yourself and then you tell yourself I
have to do this I have to commit to it I
have to make it happen then if you stick
to your guns then things beautiful
things happen and that's exactly how the
whole thing panned out now let's talk
about the two biggest lessons about
language ring that I've learned from
writing this book the first one is about
feeling the language versus just
learning it you have to learn a language
with your heart not just with your brain
and what I mean by that is that you have
to fall in love with a language you have
to fall in love with the World Behind it
the culture you have to see a purpose
you have to see your motive you have to
see reasons why you're learning a
language because you can learn all the
strategies in the world all the
effective methods of these polyglots
that are here on YouTube and on the
internet in general but if you don't
fall in love with the language if you
don't fall in love with the process of
learning a language that you're not
bound to do it they in and day out you
have to learn a language for a long time
if you want to speak it fluently so
remember that you have to feel a
language you have to feel profound
emotions towards the language if you
want to make it happen every single day
the second lesson I've learned is that
psychology plays a gigantic role in
language learning your mindset plays a
gigantic role I'm pretty sure that no
matter where you come from you've never
heard about the role of psychology in
language learning in school we tend to
learn techniques strategies how to learn
vocabulary how to learn grammar and
everything in between but people don't
talk about mindset and mindset is the
set of beliefs that you hold and
entertain towards yourself towards the
language towards its native speakers and
everything in between and come to think
of it a lot of people and this comes
from my own experience as a coach have
these limiting beliefs things like I'm
not good enough my memory is bad I
cannot learn vocabulary I'm not even
sure if I can learn this language people
doubt themselves but these limiting
beliefs are false they come from hearsay
they come from your environment since
you're a little kid you kept hearing
these things maybe from your teachers
from your schoolmates from your family
member and your emotional Pro the
emotional part of your brain believes
them and what is really holding you back
from learning a language is not a lack
of techniques it's not a lack of you
know techniques and strategies on how to
learn vocabulary or grammar and whatnot
it's these limiting beliefs if you learn
how to transform these Liberty beliefs
into liberating truths and trust me you
can then there is no stopping you from
learning any language that you want
how do I know all this it's because I
felt it too
30 years ago when I started learning
English I felt like I was useless I felt
like I would never ever learn English
because I was at school and I was trying
to learn English with and through the
traditional methods and to no avail and
my English teacher was telling me that I
was not caught for this and I remember
one day I started watching a movie and
that movie was Back to the Future one I
had seen the movie multiple times
thousands of times in Italian because I
loved it and I started watching it with
a sense of hope that finally maybe I
could understand something that all
those two years I had spent a school
learning English were you know useful
and I realized that I did not understand
much and that was an important moment an
important moment because I felt really
inside the desperation the frustration I
thought I'm never gonna learn English
I'm not good at this
but I think that that moment was pivotal
Because deep inside when I touched Rock
Bottom I just found the mental resources
and the mentality the mindset to say
okay but maybe this is not true and
you know the magic sometimes you know
magic hits in your life and my parents
hired a tutor an American tutor and from
there I started learning English in a
different way and I started learning it
well and after starting you know
learning English in a in a brain
friendly way I just learned a lot of
other languages so my transformation
from timid speaker to confident speaker
and polyglot happened because of a
change of mindset so with time with
strategies with effective techniques I
overcame these limiting beliefs I
started believing in myself I started
believing that I could learn any
language
but while I overcame my own limiting
beliefs I had to overcome another
person's limiting beliefs my father
you see my father was a mathematician
and an engineer and he wanted me to
follow his steps he kept telling me that
you know in order to make ends meet you
have to pursue a scientific career
and I told him dad I want to learn
languages and he said well you can learn
languages but you can learn languages on
the side while you follow lectures at
University and you get your degree in
engineering and that's what I did so for
years I was at University and I was
learning mathematics engineering and
whatnot
but at the end of the day after getting
my degree I was thinking this is not for
me my heart was not beating for
engineering or physics or mathematics my
heart was beating for language learning
my father was a little bit disappointed
but fast forward to many years later I
gave an interview on National Italian
radio and I said something out of thin
air
you cannot be taught a language nobody
can teach you a language you have to
learn it by yourself
and you know what
I came back home that afternoon and my
father looked at me in the eyes and
there was a different gaze that was a
different light to them
and he said well done I love the
interview
and and then and there it hit me I had
my father's approval after so many years
my father had finally understood that my
heart was beating for language learning
I talk about all this and more in the
book that I've just released and let me
tell you something it was not easy it
was actually quite difficult for me to
share my vulnerabilities my struggles
and my doubts but I think it's well
worth it I think that when you share
secrets that you think you should never
confess to the rest of the world and
that you hold close to your chest I
think these are the things that people
actually relate to the most
and I think that at the end of the day
if you want to get rewards you have to
take risks this is exactly how it works
in language learning as well you have to
take risks you have to get out of your
comfort zone you have to try new things
and you can mold you start molding your
insecurities into something powerful
because you have the potential of
learning any language you have the
potential of learning anything you just
have to tap into your own potential
now the last thing I want to tell you is
that going through this book is just
going through an experience in and of
itself the book is in digital format so
you can read it but you can also listen
to the audiobook that I recorded in a
recording studio in Rome you can listen
and read at the same time and you can
even watch some very cool interviews
that I made with my friend and colleague
Alex we had a lot of fun Alex knows how
to ask questions and we went through
other Life episodes and other
interesting experiences that we both had
related to language learning so this is
it in a nutshell I wanted to thank you
for all those who've bought the book and
left such nice reviews and nice comments
and for those who haven't bought yet if
you haven't bought it yet all you need
to do is to click on the link in the
description box or in the comment that I
pinned in the comment section thank you
very much and thanks for watching and
happy language learning